[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 19 mai voici les
titres un premier déplacement en tant
que premier ministre c'était dans les
yvelines elizabeth banks s'est rendu en
début d'après midi aux mureaux et ya
rencontré des associations qui agissent
en faveur de l'égalité des chances et de
l'émancipation des jeunes filles dans le
même temps l'annoncé du nouveau
gouvernement se fait toujours attendre
première phase de travaux terminés pour
le château de dampierre en yvelines la
fin de la restauration du clos et
couvert du corps central de l'édifice a
été célébrée ce jeudi par une cérémonie
un chantier lancé début 2001 d'autres
sont à venir pour faire renaître ce
domaine du xviie siècle et puis pendant
quatre jours le gymnase mont boron de
versailles a accueilli le championnat de
france unss de handball des cadets
garçons un retour des événements pour
l'union nationale du sport et du sport
scolaire après deux années de crise
sanitaire les gymnases ya des lycées
étaient au programme aussi cette semaine
à rambouillet nous en parlons avec nos
invités mais avant de développer ces
titres il a fait très chaud la nuit
dernière en ile-de-france 20,3 degrés c
la température provisoire à relever dans
la nuit de mercredi à jeudi à la station
montsouris de météo france à paris soit
la plus douce jamais mesuré selon
l'établissement et même la minimale au
dessus de 20 degrés la plus précoce en
150 ans de mesures et des relevés
similaires ont été faits au bourget à
roissy encore vélizy villacoublay dans
les yvelines d'ennemis au dessus de 20
degrés sont considérés comme tropicale
selon météo france et notre première à
vous signaler qu'ils nous aient relayé
par météo france cet après midi les
températures ont dépassé les normales de
saison pendant 38 jours consécutifs en
ile-de-france qui est un record le
dernier record datait et de 2020 avec 37
jours au dessus des normales de saison
je vous en parlais l'actualité du jour
c'est ce déplacement d'elisabeth bornes
première ministre dans les mureaux elle
a effectué ce premier déplacement et
pour y revenir justement céline charge
de la rédaction tv 78 bonsoir c'est un
premier déplacement symbolique on peut
dire oui un déplacement symbolique donc
pour son premier déplacement les
abattent board qui a été nommée première
ministre lundi dernier a choisi
l'égalité des chances elle s'est rendue
ce jeudi aux mureaux plus précisément au
pôle molière un lieu qui accueille une
crèche une école maternelle et une école
primaire elle ya rencontré plusieurs
associations locales et nationales
mobiliser en faveur de l'égalité et de m
si passion des femmes un sujet qui lui
tenait particulièrement à coeur et qui
s'inscrit dans la lignée de son discours
de passation elle avait dédié sa
nomination je cite à toutes les petites
filles on écoute ces quelques mots sur
place je ne peux pas accepter et je
pense qu'une personne ne devrait
accepter qu'un jeune reste sur le bord
de la route parce qu'il n'a pas la bonne
adresse les bons codes les bons réseaux
et donc aujourd'hui c'était important
pour moi d'échanger avec ces jeunes
filles et ces jeunes femmes sur la façon
dont on peut les aider elles ont
beaucoup 10,1 finalement on l'a entendu
dans tous les échanges c'est d'abord de
reprendre confiance en soi ou de prendre
confiance en soi après d'arriver à avoir
des rêves et ensuite c'est notre
responsabilité d'accompagner toutes ces
jeunes filles et ces jeunes femmes pour
qu'elles puissent les réaliser alors
lors de cette visite la première
ministre a pu échanger avec les
associations et surtout des jeunes
femmes aidées par ces associations par
exemple on retrouve l'académie des
pluriels qui se situe aux mureaux c'est
une association qui a pour vocation de
redonner le goût et le pouvoir d'agir
aux jeunes de 19 à 27 ans l'association
c'est 50% de jeunes en emploi stage ou
service civique après la formation et
30% reprise d'études c'était l'occasion
de présenter de façon concrète ce qui se
passe sur le terrain au gouvernement je
représente la station l'académie pure
haine c'est un accent qui met en place
des parcours pour les jeunes et
spécifiquement pour les femmes pour
travailler sur l'empowerment féminin le
goût de l'engagement et retrouver le
pouvoir d'agir pour les femmes
l'académie tude déploré l es propose
vraiment quelque chose de bon en fait
c'est dans le concret ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas l'impression que vraiment on vit
sans juste une expérience
professionnelle on a l'impression qu'on
vit une expérience humaine aussi et
c'est ça qui est génial parce que ils
prennent en compte tout le monde et on
le rappelle d'ailleurs elisabeth borne
est la première femme à occuper le poste
de premier ministre depuis le départ dès
le départ d'edith cresson en 1992 un
échange qui était donc aussi inspirants
pour les jeunes femmes présentes sur
place une fierté également pour la ville
des mureaux qui est souvent terre
d'accueil pour les membres du
gouvernement les murs on est une ville
laboratoire une ville
aujourd'hui ce sera la 120e visites de
ministres donc je ne sais pas si les
murs on est un passage obligatoire en
tant que telle ou pas bon mais bon je
crois que elle vient parce que il ya
plein de sujets sur lequel on a aussi
mais des actions concrètes quoi et c'est
une visite de terrain qui s'inscrit dans
la tente du remaniement du gouvernement
ils devraient être connus dans les jours
à venir mais la date d'annoncé n'a
toujours pas été dévoilé c'est un peu le
dossier chaud sur la table de la
première ministre qui a donc fait son
premier déplacement en tant que premier
ministre dans les yvelines c'était aux
mureaux cet après midi merci céline
charles pour toutes ces précisions on
quitte à présent quelques instants le
direct de ce journal pour parler des
élections législatives dans les yvelines
[Musique]
les législatives approchent les
électeurs éliront leurs députés les 12
et 19 juin prochain tv 78,2 vous aide à
y voir plus clair et vous dresse les
enjeux du scrutin dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines ce soir et
directions direction la 5e
circonscription avec patrice carmouze
bonsoir bonsoir directeur de
l'information de tv 78 déjà
géographiquement où se trouve cette 5ème
circonscription l'alsace compte dans le
nord-est du département si on veut
situer cette ville de maisons-laffitte
sartrouville le vésinet le mesnil le roi
est monté son
c'est une circonscription quatre
législatures était celle de du maire de
maisons laffitte jacques myard vos
séries qui était un gaulliste bon
couleurs assez souverainiste alors on
pensait qu'il allait peut-être être
réélu but en 2017 et uva sauver cette
vague macro nist et il était emporté par
par cette vague mais c'est une avocate
qui a été élu à sa place qui est elle
broute iv qui est une danse et les
membres d'ailleurs du parti socialiste
il ya de la main gauche alors ayez le
bronze bv est devenue une mort important
de la majorité macro nice telle est la
présidente de la commission des lois qui
est une commission importante c'est à
dire la première femme présidente d'une
commission qui n'avait jamais été élu
député avant et c'est juste la deuxième
femme présidente de la commission des
lois la première c'était une autre élu
dans les yvelines qui m'est ministre de
mitterrand c'était catherine tasca et
donc face à jan van de vyver on retrouve
trois femmes trois femmes et trois
femmes importantes la première c'est
alex andrade du blanche et conseiller
régional qui est a dit au maire de
sartrouville et qui est très proche de
valérie pécresse
d'ailleurs eu la côtoient au conseil
régional
elle bénéficie d'une bonne image de
femme dynamique bien implanté
régionalement et localement
et puis une petite tablette d'autres qui
est assez amusante vous savez qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de mckinsey pendant la
campagne présidentielle pour leur
prochain maintenant bat alexandre des
blanches elle a commencé sa carrière
chez chez mec c'est vraiment ça donne
c'est un petit détail qui est sans
importance le son problème c'est de
savoir à mal si elle va pâtir du mauvais
score de valérie pécresse aux
présidentielles celle au pouvoir se sont
détachés ce sera toute la question de
qui va se poser pendant sept dans cette
circonscription et qui sont les autres
candidats patrice alors à gauche pour la
nouvelle union populaire c'est une mort
de deux de l afic et sophie thévenet
sophie thévenet elle avait déjà été
candidate en 2017 aux lèvres a obtenu 1
8 25% des voix mais là bas les données
sont un peu différente puisque jean luc
mélenchon à la grande surprise à la
surprise générale a été le premier à
sartrouville et la dune 34% des voix à
sartrouville donc
pas suffisant pour lui permettre d'être
élu mais peut-être qu'elle peut rêver à
créer la surprise pourquoi pas à la
figure au 2e tour et puis côté et rennes
c'est aussi une femme qu on puisse et
une députée européenne matip nord drouet
qui sera candidate est là le r n est pas
très très fort dans cette
circonscription dont on peut penser que
c'est surtout une candidature de
témoignage de la part de matignon merci
patrice carmouze pour ces précisions
[Musique]
ils sont également candidats dans cette
cinquième circonscription des yvelines
alain à l'épicier pour lutte ouvrière
maxime bringuet pour reconquête jean-luc
donné pour le parti animalistes et diane
lagrange pour la république souveraine
les dates du scrutin les 12 et 19 juin
prochains pour ces élections
législatives la protection des données
un enjeu important primordial même pour
le niveau international pour les
collectivités publiques les entreprises
mais aussi pour notre vie privée le
mouvement européen des yvelines organise
un grand colloque sur la cybersécurité
la cyberdéfense il se déroulera le mardi
24 mai de 16h 30 à 22 heures au théâtre
montansier à versailles plusieurs
experts européens et français du sujet
seront présents pour l'occasion avec des
ateliers dès 17h et une conférence à 20
heures on écoute fils big n du mouvement
européen des yvelines un sujet qui est
peu traité encore mais qui justement est
le sujet de demain peut-être la guerre
économique et la guerre invisible les
drm et qui qui nous touche tous en tant
que citoyens puisque nos données peuvent
aussi piraté et utilisé
par son par ces cyber attaques il
s'agissait de philippe le guen et non de
philippe guynemer des clayes-sous-bois
le grand colloque sur la cyber sécurité
organisée par le mouvement européen des
yvelines et c'est au programme le mardi
24 mai de 16h 30 à 22 heures au théâtre
montansier de versailles
[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce jeudi 19 mai
également le château de dampierre en
yvelines retrouve petit à petit sa
splendeur la première phase de travaux
est terminée on retrouve sur place c'est
yaga 200 go accompagnée de justin
bradier brasier qui ont assisté à la
dépose du filet du chantier ce matin on
le voit tomber derrière moi le filet du
chantier du château de dampierre en
yvelines c'est la fin de la première
phase d'un chantier de restauration
lancé en 2020 pour le clos et couvert du
corps central du château l'occasion de
découvrir à présent sa nouvelle robe
avec les enduits et briques rénové et
aussi les charpentes et couvertures
restaurer une boîte commémorative a été
déposée par le propriétaire du château
franky mulliez
sous les ardoises d'une des deux tours
l2 la façade nord deux dans un parchemin
avec eux tous les noms des compagnons
représentant tous les corps d'état
intervenu durant le chantier en chiffres
la restauration c'est 3600 mètres carrés
déjà faux d'âge 870 mètres carrés deux
fils est imprimée ou encore 113 mètres
cubes de pierres de taille à poser les
échafaudages seront enlevés dans les
prochaines semaines pour une phase de
démontage complet fin juillet
avant de parler sport scolaire direction
la croisette le 75e festival de cannes
se déroule jusqu'au 28 mai radio
sensations en partenariat avec tv 78
vous fait vivre l'événement de
l'intérieur en allant à la rencontre de
producteurs réalisateurs et acteurs de
la région corentin alonso vous emmène ce
soir à l'intérieur du palais des
festivals il a pu assister à la
conférence de presse de couper le
dernier film de michel hazanavicius qui
a fait l'ouverture l'événement et qui a
été tourné en ile de france est aussi
financé par la région francilienne
cannes sa croisette ses plages et son
palais des festivals d'ailleurs est-ce
que vous êtes déjà rentrés dedans allez
je vous dis en mai
[Musique]
ok
12h25
[Musique]
on se retrouve dans la salle de la
conférence de presse du festival de
cannes le film coupé réalisé par michel
hazanavicius sera présenté aujourd'hui
les acteurs le réalisateur aussi seront
présents pour parler du film aux
journalistes ici ça va commencer dans
quelques minutes à venir ici ouvrir un
festival avec un film joyeux c'est
à la fois étrange et un grand honneur ou
alors c'est une centaine de journalistes
présents ils sont espagnols américains
ou encore japonais et viennent poser
leurs questions à l'équipe du film et
moi aussi je vais me lancer comment
est-ce qu'on choisit un des lieux de
tournage qu'elle et yale et les
contraintes que vous aviez on allait à
bondoufle
qu'une ville
aïe enfin bon c'est à 50 km de paris on
est dans un hippodrome abandonné dans
lequel il ya des chevreuils des
sangliers moi je cherchais un lieu dont
d'abord qui
esthétiquement on colle aux films et
et qui en plus est une espèce de
topologie qui me permettait d'avoir les
courses les trucs les kachins 2 2 voilà
tout ce dont j'avais besoin et en plus
il est très pop ce saulieu donc j'ai ça
a été vraiment énorme coup de bol tu
m'avais j'ai un coup de bol pour ce
tournage l'histoire d'un film de zombies
dans un film et pour le spectateur de
vision d'un même récit jamais un slip au
début on voit quelque chose ou mais
forcément mis en tant que spectateur
dans une situation de critique et de
jugement on juge qu'on est hostile c'est
de la daube je suis en train de regarder
un navet intersidéral et puis l'histoire
se raconte autrement on change de point
de vue de perspectives et tout d'un coup
on est critique par rapport à son propre
jugement et en fait on fait une
expérience de bienveillance et ça je
trouve que j'aimais beaucoup ça
et maintenant il ne vous reste plus qu'à
aller voir le film dans les salles de
cinéma est la suite des festivités au
festival de cannes à sucre bien sûr dans
le 7-8 journal on va refermer ce journal
en parlant du sport scolaire qui était à
l'honneur cette semaine dans les
yvelines deux événements notamment sur
lesquels nous allons revenir avec nos
invités par visioconférence il ya killed
in albert bonsoir
directrice du service départemental des
yvelines de l'urss l'union nationale du
sport scolaire alors depuis lundi et est
au programme un championnat de france
unss de handball catégorie cadets
garçons 16 meilleures équipes de france
se sont retrouvés au gymnase mont boron
et la finale a eu lieu ce jeudi après
midi entre pau et toulouse gagner au but
en or par toulouse sur le score de 24 23
sur la troisième marche du podium on
retrouve un établissements franciliens
de créteil quel premier bilan vous fait
de cet événement je me disais qu'il
s'est déroulé pendant quatre jours là
ils viennent de se terminer
alors une grande réussite on est
vraiment fiers parce que les bains le
handball est une activité qu'on n'a pas
pu oui pendant deux ans
les salaires on peut
vraiment pas
hélas de voir c'était
vraiment choqué
il y avait un autre événement hier
mercredi stehlé gymnasiades du district
unss lycée à rambouillet 500 élèves
venus des lycées de maurepas guyancourt
trappe la queue-lez-yvelines montigny le
bretonneux et rambouillet qui se sont
retrouvés avec des rencontres autour
d'activités sportives du football du
volley ball du badminton du basket un
relais cross est du tir à la corde le
vainqueur cette année ces lycées et des
tirs de montigny-le-bretonneux
d'ailleurs voici le trophée de cet
événement qui a été réalisé par les
élèves du lycée louis-blériot de trappes
pour en parler deux invités qui sont
avec moi en plateau c'est nathalie à
cayeux bonsoir est également thomas
scellier bonsoir voila que je repose le
trophée vous êtes tous les deux un
coordinateur du district sud lycée sud
yvelines lycée pour lui nss pareil même
question que pour qu'ils dînent albert
premier bilan de cet événement en plus
on le rappelle organisée après deux
années de crise sanitaire nathalie
canieux oui bilan très positif je pense
que tout le monde était content de
pouvoir reprendre que ce soit du côté
des élèves et du collège et des
collègues vraiment des images de joie il
y avait une vraie volonté thomas c'est
de se retrouver après deux années
d'annulation d'événements oui d'ailleurs
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes puisque
on a eu plus d'élèves qu'avant qu'ovide
on était plutôt autour de 400 là on a je
pense dépasser pour la première fois les
cinq sens c'était attendu et puis les
élèves ont répondu présent dernier
moment parce qu'il y avait les épreuves
de spécialités la semaine d'avant au
lycée l'épreuve du bac donc compliquée
pour recruter et en peu de temps
il était à fond comme avant le coït il
ya un défi un challenge
46e suprématie et l'élu qui sont entre
les races et on sera l'occasion d'en
reparler tous attendent alors on va
revenir au championnat de france de
handball qui se déroulait je vous le
disais unss du côté du gymnase mont
boron de versailles vous l'avez dit
qu'il dîne albert y avait une vraie
volonté de se retrouver c'est un peu le
sentiment qui prédomine après ces deux
années de crise sanitaire comment l'urss
des yvelines s'est elle retrouvée
justement organisé cet événement
alors chaque année on organise un
championnat de france
et comme on est une fédération
ac service en fonte
et l'année prochaine sans doute même si
ce n'est pas encore accusé
et ce sera toujours à versailles où
justement où vous aller voguer peut-être
dans d'autres villes des yvelines
mais on sait qu'il ya un site olympique
en plus concernant le golf du côté du
golf national de saint quentin en in le
sport scolaire en quoi est-il important
pour ces jeunes qu'ils dînent albert
alors c'est important parce que c'est la
première non dans le club c'est
accessible à tous la licence est entre
20 et 30 euros divine dans tous les
collèges et dans tous les lycées donc il
ya une offre multiple et d'activités
était vraiment un moment où ils peuvent
se retrouver des cas la fois pour
apprendre la vie associative on va des
gamins vitre on a déjà le coach en a
déjà deux reporters donc c'est vraiment
un moment de wii peuvent voilà
complètement fait tout ce qu'il fait
dans la vie de collégien ou lycéen et
donc on les encourage à venir voir leurs
professeurs de paix et d appliquer le
sport scolaire
d'ailleurs on a deux professeurs de ps1
je n'ai pas précisées en plateau lycée
descartes de montigny et j'ai oublié les
lycées breteuil de montigny voilà deux
lycées de montigny on va écouter
quelques réactions des lèvres collecter
justement gymnase mont boron par patrick
jacques de dixmude
génial l'hébergement pareil
franchement un manager c'est une très
bonne compétition il ya beaucoup de bons
joueurs y avait du bon niveau
la plupart des équipes avec des
handballeurs
de voir s'améliorer sur certains points
comme
leur aspect d'antan le client
on adore j'ai adoré ce championnat je
l'adoré pour plusieurs raisons jha prêt
à manger trop et que l'organisation
était incroyable c'était super bien
organisé de a à z les transports le
logement ex terrasse est incroyable et
ensuite j'ai adoré l'ambiance qui avait
parce que entre chaque équipe tu avais
de la cohésion et donc qui s'est conclue
avec une finale remportée par toulouse
face à pau
24-23 il ya eu toute une organisation
derrière aussi qu'il dîne avec une
soixantaine
d'organisateurs dans l'équipe des jeunes
aussi qui ont participé directement à
cette organisation
adultes donc pour le ps est membre
et on a dix jeunes de saint cyr et de
versailles que nous ont légué à john
organisateurs qu'ils ont permis de
rentrer les secours sur big bore est de
faire en sorte que baver les familles et
les extérieurs puissent suivre les
matchs en temps réel et des jeunes
reporters qu'elles ont permis de faire
rayonner aussi ce championnat c'est
pourquoi c'est important de les
impliquer dans l'organisation ça fait
partie aussi des valeurs de l'urss de
s'impliquer directement dans ce genre
d'événement bien complètement on dit
vraiment de
totalité à prendre et associatives et
pratique sportive en clair on essaye de
faire des événements pour les élèves et
par les élèves donc il se forge une
expérience moi c'était carrément à
championnat 3m était nouveau district on
les encourage à participer aux
événements et à aider les professeurs
étaient vraiment là qu on est ravis
quand on voit qu'ils prennent plaisir à
maman
et on va direction rambouillet 1 je le
disais avec cet événement aussi qui
s'est déroulé cette semaine celle et
gimnasia d'un événement annuel pour les
lycées du district du sud yvelines 500
élèves qui étaient venus des lycées de
maurepas guyancourt trappe la
queue-lez-yvelines montigny le
bretonneux et rambouillet avec le
trophée un que je tiens dans mes mains
qui a été remportée cette année par le
lycée descartes c'est bien ça à
montigny-le-bretonneux les objectifs de
l'événement qu'elle quels sont-ils
pourquoi aussi organiser ce genre
d'événements chaque année alors cet
événement vient conclure une année en
une année
les élèves se sont rencontrés lors de
divers rencontre pendant l'année mais
pas forcément tous ensemble et là chaque
et chaque établissement constitue sa
meilleure équipe en tout cas pour venir
se rencontrer et c'est vraiment un
moment convivial qu'on souhaite partager
en fin d'année commencent à s'organiser
en plus deux ans d'absence ça fait
plusieurs mois que vous êtes sur le coup
ça fait plusieurs mois mais
l'organisation est assez rodée on
remercie d'ailleurs les collègues de
rambouillet qui nous accueille depuis
depuis trois quatre ans maintenant
donc c'est du meiling on se répartit on
prévoit d'être là le matin avec une
équipe d'organisateurs pour installer
puis après on se répartit les tâches
l'après midi et ça fonctionne plutôt
bien avec des arbitres des organisateurs
du secrétariat c'est une journée très
intense on va pas se mentir mais on est
content de voir quant aux tirs aboutir à
la corde à la fin c'est la liesse à
chaque victoire oui ça crée une certaine
émulation et ont commencé à en parler
quelles sont les valeurs qu'elle que
vous souhaitez porter à notre art du nss
pourquoi c'est important selon vous le
sport scolaire le sport scolaire c'est
que ça permet de proposer une pratique
comme l'a dit qu'il dîne à moindre coût
accessible c'est un complément pour les
pratiquants en club
ça offre aussi il ya un aspect convivial
c'est de la compétition avec une
convivialité
je pense
voilà une approche différente on crée un
esprit 10 et pour le coup pour ce qui
est des gymnasiades et puis il ya le
côté formation responsabilités alors
c'est vrai que nous sur les gymnasiades
on est quand même purement sur la
pratique avant tout on avait peut-être
quelques reporters mais sinon tout au
long de l'année on forme des jeunes
organisateurs des jeunes arbitres ça
peut servir pour parcours sup aussi pour
la suite pour lorient création pour
valoriser leur cursus donc voilà il ya
une formation une éducation citoyenne
ces retards du sport mais il ya toute
une éducation citoyenne alors ces
activités on le précise qui se pratique
le mercredi après midi c'est pas trop
difficile de s'organiser nathalie cayeux
on sait que moi c'était mon cas quand
j'étais au lycée des fois on a des cours
l'après midi avec les élèves qui ont les
cours l'après-midi de pouvoir leur
permettre de pratiquer le sport quand
même alors effectivement les actus
tellez se passe le mercredi après-midi
principalement notamment les rencontres
on a nous la problématique en lice est
de plus en plus d'avoir des cours le
mercredi après midi c'est pas une
problématique qui arrive pour l'instant
au collège mais la réforme du lycée
effectivement à fait qu'avec les
alignements de spécialités les
établissements de d'énormes contraintes
sur les emplois du temps et nous en tant
que coordinateur de district on se rend
bien compte de la difficulté en tout cas
pour développer le sport scolaire au
lycée
mercredi après-midi effectivement vous
avez des craintes de ce point de vue là
que ça puisse peut-être empirer à
l'avenir oui puisqu'on le voit ça évolue
déjà
dans d'autres districts maintenant
l'année prochaine y aura uniquement deux
établissements qui n'auront pas cours le
mercredi après midi donc compliqué de se
rencontrer canton à court d'idées albert
c'est une problématique au niveau
départemental oui
mais nous on comprend aussi la le besoin
des élèves d'avoir une activité physique
par contre vous pour qu'on gagne en
nombre de pratiquants en france pour une
meilleure santé pour leur trouver leur
permettre d'avoir des pratiques donc on
arrive à discuter et à trouver les
moyens pour permettre cette pratique ou
d'hélène et surtout sur répondu
permettent une ouverture vers
l'extérieur et
godard application très pratique alors
une cession déjà sur le nombre de
pratiquants du sport scolaire dans les
yvelines vous en avez une idée combien
pratique
les milieux la meilleure amie on était à
près de 28
on est bien placé
avec un département l'a compris divisé
en plusieurs districts et notamment le
district sud yvelines questions très
pratiques pour terminer comment
pratiquer justement à lui est né cesse
comment pratiquer dans l'est dans les
associations sportives des
établissements scolaires comment faire
du sport scolaire tout simplement
renseignés
département fans sur internet via nos
coordonnées et puis si 26 s'investir en
tant que prêteur mais en tant que d'un
organisateur
nous les valides ils ont un diplôme
notamment pourquoi pur sucre et donc on
ouvre la porte à tout le monde bienvenue
et plus d'informations d'ailleurs sur
lui et naissait sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci à nos
trois invités d'avoir été avec nous et
qu'il dîne albert directrice du service
départemental des yvelines de l'urss qui
étaient avec nous par visio conférence
est avec nous en plateau les deux
coordinateurs du district sud-yvelines
lycée de l'urss nathalie à cayeux qui
étaient avec nous également thomas
scellier merci d'avoir été avec nous et
longue vie à lui est né cesse on
l'espère voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal vous l'espérez aussi merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi vous
retrouverez le 7-8 week-end de
l'actualité des idées de sorties pour
bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]